one of the things in terms of leadership
that I found is you really do have to
wear every hat before you can ask other
people to do it so with with toms shoes
even though we've grown really fast I
have you know kind of worn every single
hat along the way I might have only worn
it for a week or two but at least when I
hired that person or brought that person
on you know I've been able to say these
are the challenges these are the
opportunities and go after it and with
that point one of the things that I
really kind of is a cornerstone of my
business philosophy and leadership is
really not to micromanage people just
let it higher spend a lot of time making
that decision on who to hire but once
you hire them just let them go and it's
very interesting and that i am only in
the office maybe five or six days a
month and there's our times and i'm not
in the office for two months at a time
so you can imagine a fast growing
company of a lot of young people who
don't have a lot of experience with a
boss that's only 31 years old who's
never around so it really takes a lot of
trust in the people that you have and
you also have to be a good leader from
afar you've got to be able to use
technology and tools available to lead
people and so that's one thing that I
think that I have an advantage being
young over a lot of older CEOs is that I
really embrace the use of technology
writing a blog you keeping the whole
team kind of understanding what i'm
doing every day when they don't see me
every day